le verdict est donc tombé vendredi soir
les organisateurs de la fête clandestine
qui s'est déroulé dans une à caves
troglodytes à montlouis le 12 décembre
en pleine crise sanitaire ont finalement
été condamnés à 2 110 et 140 heures de
travaux d'intérêt général
le tribunal a estimé que le but de cette
soirée d'anniversaire était bien de
gagner de l'argent
une décision qui pourrait donner le ton
des autres jugement attendu pour des
affaires similaires
retour sur les faits avec lucas chopin
c'est dans une cave troglodytiques comme
celle ci que se déroulent les faits dans
la nuit du 12 au 13 décembre dernier les
forces de l'ordre sont appelés pour une
dispute rue de la gaude elle rit à
montlouis sur loire
sur place elle découvre 100 à 150
personnes réunies pour une fête malgré
le confinement
on célèbre l'anniversaire de claire 24
ans et c'est giresse 23 ans et dj qu'il
organise à la barre les deux jeunes
reconnaissent une erreur mais avoue
avoir été dépassé par le bouche à
oreille des réseaux sociaux
le dj admettent avoir été appâté par le
gain de cette soirée payante
problème la procureure distingue les
petites fêtes entre jeunes ont soif de
liberté et celles à but lucratif comme
celle ci giresse est reconnu coupable de
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui est
clair pour complicité de mise en danger
de la vie d'autrui
au vu de la situation sanitaire ils sont
respectivement condamnés à 2 110 et 140
heures de travail d'intérêt général
une peine justifié selon la jeune femme
moi je la comprends parce que comme on a
dit lors du procès c'est qu'on prend
conscience des choses on prend
conscience de la situation actuelle et
on doit en fait on doit affronter ce qui
est fait quoi neuf sur cette approche on
de dire ça va être très grave au niveau
des peines on s'imagine la prison la
moins touchée soulager la faire aller
régler et maintenant bas on applique à
appliquer la peine qu'on a eu c'est tout
son avocat avait plaidé la relaxe
estimant que la mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui étaient infondées il reconnaît
cependant une condamnation adaptée au
profil des prévenus
aujourd'hui le tribunal correctionnel
condamne les prévenus à des peines de
travail d'intérêt général
donc c'est une décision qui est
particulièrement humaine qui tient
compte de leur situation personnelle
voilà ça reste satisfaisant même si sur
le fond clairement juridiquement
voilà ça me laisse à moi un petit goût
amer cette condamnation est la première
du genre en france
le président du tribunal aimerait voir
les deux jeunes la purger dans un
établissement prenant en charge les
malades de l'aco vide